all right guys congratulations
you both made it to round three of the
competition where we will send you to
your home forges for four days
to make this iconic weapon from u.s
military history
and that weapon is the springfield 1905
bayonet
we will be providing a springfield 1903
replica rifle to you
your bayonets must fit snugly
and securely on your rifles
developed in the early 1900s the m1905
springfield bayonet was used by american
infantry
for nearly 70 years from world war one
through the vietnam war
these versatile weapons were designed
with a mechanical device in the pommel
that attached securely to the rifle
while also featuring a comfortable
handle making it a very
effective weapon in hand-to-hand combat
featuring a sharp single edge
a long fuller and a false edge this
lightweight bayonet can quickly deliver
stabs and slashes to an opponent the
bayonet is still used today during
military ceremonies
and can be seen in several classic war
films like 1998's the thin red line
all right gentlemen when you guys build
your bayonets i want you to follow these
parameters the blade needs to be between
15
and 16 inches with a fuller and a false
edge at the tip
as well as a muzzle ring guard i'm a
little nervous with it
never done a guard on a knife before
along with a keyhole and i know with the
bayonets they usually have
a place in the back of the handle where
it locks into the rifle there's a lot of
first
all right gentlemen good luck we'll see
you in four days good luck man
my main plan is to get the whole blade
forged out i guess i could grind it to
shape
but then it's not forging fire
i have everything forged out pullers are
in rough dimensions are there
i'm happy so right now i have my groove
cut
these are going to be the rest of my
pommel
they are going to go like so and then be
welded like that
so i have to use my angle grinder very
very
very carefully and scribe this line in
thick enough that it fits on those rails
line everything up
it works i got my scales all cut out
they fit relatively nice now i'm working
on getting my pen
but that's gonna look pretty cool when
it's done i have my knife all glued up
now that it's dry i'm ready to take the
clamps off and we'll start profiling the
handle
at the end process it's probably one of
the best things i've made i'm pretty
proud of this
so i'm back in lancaster ohio at my home
forge i've never made anything this big
[Music]
all before so i got the edges cleaned up
fairly well overall my knife is pretty
straight
it's got some little wobbles on there
but that's from forging
a little less than an eighth of an inch
to remove from this thing and we're good
i'm going to punch my knife there's a
lot of things that can go wrong in this
process
let's do this
so i'm not hearing any weird noises or
any pings so i think i'm in good shape
the biggest challenge of this build is
getting that locking mechanism to work
so now we're going to test fit this
there she is i try to really pride
myself on my fit and finish
and i'm pretty confident in my knife i'm
really happy with it
i wouldn't want to be on the other end
of this thing let's see what it does
yeah this thing is sweet
let's see
this thing is sharp dude that didn't
make any noise it just stabbed right
through it
blade spits welcome to the kill test
the first mission today is to take your
bayonet and affix it to the springfield
rifle
and deliver some killing blows on this
ballistics dummy
then i will dismantle the blade from the
rifle
and let's see what kind of lethal damage
it will do on its own josh you're up
first you ready
let's raise the can be
[Music]
that's pretty badass all right josh
let's talk about your bayonet here
when i affixed this onto the rifle it
had a very
nice match with the railing in there and
your pin it was very secure
now your edge is very sharp it
definitely lacerates deep
into the bone on its own the handle
construction matches nicely on my hand
overall sir it will keel awesome thank
you
all right brad your turn so you ready
for this let's go for it
all right brad first up the handle
construction it is a little bit on the
smaller side
but there are no sharp edges and the
flare you have here actually gives me
good retention and i can get all the way
to the guard
at first i was a little bit worried
about your cutter pin right here it
looked flimsy
but the minute i put it on it wasn't an
issue at all it stayed affixed to the
bayonet quite tightly
your weapon is straight every cut was
very deep
into this ballistics dummy overall sir
your weapon
will kill thank you sir blitzmas welcome
to the strength test
the steel can stab and barricade chop
this test is all about what happens to
your bayonets and not what happens to
the targets joshua first you ready nope
nope
oh here's my finish
all right josh well you survived really
well there is
sections on here that are now not as
sharp as they were
but nothing rolled over nothing chipped
out your point is still
nice and sharp it performed really well
on the strength test nice job awesome
thank you
all right brad be ready for this well my
nan said don't break it but go for it
[Music]
well brad what you got here your blade
edge
took some damage the blade's taking a
bit of a bend to one side here
it's cheating to the right but your
point didn't take any damage
it's all in one piece it's a nice sturdy
blade nice job thank you
all right bladesmiths this is the
sharpest test the military bag slice
to find out how sharp your edges end
point of your bayonets are i'm going to
take a stab at these military bags
josh you're up first you ready let's go
for it
[Music]
all right josh your bandit right here
had no problems
puncturing the bag and slicing it to
pieces
it'll cut sweet thanks
all right brad your turn sir should we
do it of course have at you
[Music]
all right brad let's talk about your
blade here wicked sharp
it's punctured easily in the military
bag at the same time the edges
cut like hot steel on butter overall sir
for this test
you will cut thank you sir
gentlemen well you both brought us
amazing work only one of you will go
home with the title
and the fortune fire champion is
josh congratulations
brad unfortunately you're not going home
with the wind today and doug's going to
tell you why
i commend you on your work your knife
performed very well on our test but it
was also the only knife that took a bend
on the strength vest
and for that reason your blade did not
make the cut brad unfortunately that
means i'm gonna have to ask you to
please leave the forge four
i understand have a good one guys
pleasure man thank you
when it comes to the judge's final
decision i can't argue with it at all
i'm extremely proud of my work that was
probably
the best blade i've ever made so far
this has just been a dream come true
and i'm just so grateful to be where i
am right now even if i am going home
well josh that means you are the fortune
fire champion you're going home with a
check for ten thousand dollars how does
it feel bud
i feel awesome congratulations
how do you know man i'm still trying to
think in the i
won this this i want a little
overwhelming i can't wait to tell my
wife
she had a lot of confidence in me from
the very start i'm excited to let her
know that hey you
you were right you know i won
you